Chappelle
Rock
fur
one
Mulaney Maniscalco
Frazier Hart Netflix made them
handsomely and with whatever money they
had left over they got this guy
I grew up in Louisiana I grew up a lot
of homophobia I grew up with a guy
hating gay people he was obsessed with
gay guys taking the rainbow that was
like his big beef gay guys took the
rainbow I'm like that might be the
gayest complaint I've ever heard my
entire life
I'm doing all right you know I had sex
with my wife today or she calls it micro
dosing and uh
I remember one time I left the abortion
clinic with a lady and there's a guy
protesting he goes you're a goddamn
murderer he's like wow about murder are
really more just hired a hit man
and Men even treat their dicks like kids
we wash it we take care of it we name it
we go you want to see a photo people go
no thank you
the only difference is you beat your kid
at the mall nobody stops you
Mark Norman Soup To Nuts another reason
why women are better than men you don't
see a lot of female School shooters
what's going on there
I Googled it there's been two oh anybody
ever heard of them whether it's gun
violence or the WNBA
nobody's watching these female shooters
the special he's been waiting for
uh all right
[Music]
good to be here guys apparently eating
Chinese food during the episode
this is uh geez well I don't know I'm
drawing a blank the guy who was stuck on
the aisle Gilligan yeah
uh yeah does it say Happy Happy Father's
Day Dad oh yeah you're gatherer S
Thompson there we go I mean whatever
they give you have to wear you can't
like
oh they gave you that yeah Oh I thought
you bought at a thrift store because
it's kind of got a cool old look
yeah you know the guy you ever see
something about Mary there's that weird
guy who gets he's like Mary's my girl
and it says a dance contest yeah there's
holy [__] for that reminder the guy who
shoots the guy yes yes that's you dude
it's a deep cut deep reference deep but
hey here we are it's it's summer in New
York City Manhattan's hot I was sweating
dude and it's like there's noise
everywhere it's like if there's a space
where there's no noise there's like a
guy who comes in to make noise there was
a guy singing the Candyman on the subway
and I'm like they can't he has the Dandy
the doo-wop song No The Candy Man
and you had a bucket of lollipops I'm
like who's taking those lollipops
literally rule number one is you don't
take lollipops from strangers we were on
the street the other day and some guy
guys you want my album and I go I'm good
he goes I'll sign it I go give me the
album and you're like what are you doing
that's [__] rookie [__] he's gonna
charge you I know it was like a mixtape
what did it cost you I got it he got me
out of it I got him out of it you don't
do that after he signed it over no he
didn't sign it oh okay what you think he
knew his name that quickly I was on it I
was like stop it yeah that's a rookie
move because take my album what do they
give you the album then they want money
yeah yeah okay I'll be 20 bucks and
you're like oh I thought it was free and
they're like who said it was free yeah
that's their whole day that's the whole
day yeah all right well you saved me
there that was bad I felt like a real
hey seed I feel like a real pecker would
you would have done the same
no those guys are actually dangerous
that's what I'm saying there was a
shootout in Times Square with those guys
with the cops what yeah yeah what are
you talking about there was a shootout
between the the CD signing guys the cops
tried to stop them they ran and they
shot it out with a cop whoa that would
help the album
the value street cred baby yeah
50 Cent he got shot
that's uh and then when they go to jail
they they have to give up the albums oh
yeah they go in they get them that's
true they have a record yeah do you
think they're still trading cigarettes
in jail they gotta I heard Ramen was
number one currency yeah then cigarettes
I feel like it's shrimp ramen is number
one then chicken then beef yeah Seafood
is the higher quality higher quality
Ramen but yeah it's always on a Chinese
menu it'll be like or Thai it's like a
pick a protein chicken and beef 8.99
shrimp 10.99 yeah always love a good
shrimp and they give you less
it's not a galaxy of shrimp shrimp stew
shrimp gumbo shrimp creole shrimp pasta
shrimp bread shrimp and grits and yet
it's an insult you're a shrimp Ah that's
true yeah bubble gum shrimp thank you
Bubba Gump yeah all right that guy had a
bad run man
he [__] he dies and then he gets all
the pro uh the proceeds oh yeah that's a
tough one that's a tough life yeah
that was back when they always killed
the black guy in like the first half of
the movie oh yeah that was the 90s were
tough and then they had the nerve to
make The Green Mile which was like we
need another uh uh Angelic soothsayer
Prophet black guy they do that with
everything Legend a bag of Vats the
other one you know it's always like the
black guy who's who knows all or gets
killed
and every judge in a movie is black but
it was a happy ending at least in
Shawshank that's true I mean they were
in prison but yeah they met up with him
at the boat
yeah that wouldn't be you need that
Hollywood happy ending yeah I got a good
wreck for you guys
Criterion saw it the other night night
moves with uh Pac-Man Gene Hackman yeah
yeah really yeah yeah great movement 81
80. Thief came out did you ever see
Thief before Thief I haven't seen that I
know Thief okay night but who directed
that is that their pen wow well Bonnie
and Clyde action is that based on the
song by Bob Seger not at all in the
movie if not I bet it is they used to do
that they used to put them together like
staying alive I would have noticed it it
was like a slow Florida sweaty noise
wow yeah it was good man all right man
right up my anal I'm down Night Moves
I'm trying to watch every oh sorry I'm
trying to watch every uh Tarantino made
a top 10 movies what what have you
watched from it well I saw blowout
that's a great one great that was a
wreck from a few weeks back for me
that's right the young Travolta
uh hit a couple other ones what else you
got directors love the Palma I feel like
yeah it's like a director's director
that's true no one else really likes him
I need a scarf I like him I'll give him
he wrote it I don't think he directed it
really or did he direct it who directed
I thought he did direct it
oh okay I gotta see the first the second
one I have not seen
his girl Friday That's a classic yeah
that's like a like a farce right
Pandora's Box yeah I haven't seen that
see there's a lot of these unfaithfully
yours never seen that five Graves to
Cairo never seen that
Billy Wilder damn I should see that yeah
all right good list dude uh I got
another one for you another movie I just
watched and it's because it's weird I'm
I'm reading the Steve Jobs book I'm
almost done with it's really good yeah
Walter Isaac interesting guy amazingly
interesting the thing we did with the
the license plate he never bought a car
he just kept leasing it he had all these
little hacks I'm not up to that oh it
gets good so you can't get a ticket if
you have a dealer plate that was it so
he kept getting a new car for three
months so he can get a dealer plate so
he get caught speeding and they'd be
like well we can't write you a ticket he
had all these little genius twists what
the hell is beard you doing a lot is
going on here wow I got a shot of that
somebody
do not Zing the beard you this week
I know what's going on I heard you
bumped into Jay Leno about a month ago
what uh Burning Man what are we doing
here we're doing uh we're doing a little
uh special twist a beer juice on a rum
punch get a whiff of that wow
the guest is gonna [__] on this this is
great no this is fun looking at the
Chalice the fruit the the stabby thing I
love it it's uh it's a pomegranate
banana rum punch oh that's a [__] one
one fart up that's yeah get that all out
before our guest comes I don't think I
don't think he's gonna like you farting
on him very much this is one I'm
actually nervous for you yeah let's get
going this is one I don't think you can
pull off
well we'll see he doesn't want to go
back to the pen I'll tell you that I
know but I think I think just like
reflexes are gonna kick in that's true
that's true he might stab me with a
sharpened toothbrush but that we're
giving too much away here it does come
with a pick so be careful uh true it's
got a weapon
all right I gotta try this so this is a
rum punch with a by the way welcome back
from Australia oh hey good to be back
across the pond
oh that is delicious
oh man it actually tastes healthy it's
good it's tropical for the summer we're
good you know very nice what what fruit
is in there there is a pomegranate
cranberry pineapple orange and uh the
rum is plantation banana rum yeah don't
pull that out with the guest
all right what else you got huh
Cool Whip all right all right
getting it all out before he gets here
okay oh but Australia really you gotta
go I I talked to the promoter he said
they're interested okay you so uh
but yeah great time it's a whole
different world over there obviously
it's a 20-hour flight fluke coach
why just you know I gotta stay with the
people all right now I flew I flew first
class there which was unbelievable that
was the best part of the whole trip and
then I flew coach back just to get me
back to Earth because it was so fun to
get treated so well you got a tour
manager he goes that way you have a tour
manager yeah I've never had one it's a
game changer yeah it's nice the car is
there when you need it uh hey can I
never got any club soda oh I got a good
club soda coming in hot you know all
that [__] was great I hope you're using
them for more than just the club soda I
barely used them I didn't know what to
do and he was like you're the easiest
artist I've ever had I couldn't believe
how easy this was I was like we went out
every night drinking it was great that
is the weird thing about the road is I
forget how unhealthy we are sometimes on
stage is like a throwaway I didn't even
mean it to be funny but I said you know
so we're trying to be healthy on the
road I mean we do drink every night and
that gets like a huge laugh oh I guess
that's not healthy at all yeah you
forget about that we were just pounding
a bottle of wine you know before I'd go
on but then you know the next day we had
I did two weeks on the road I did on the
tour bus we were you know yeah we were
hitting it pretty [__] hard that's
what you got to do but the thing is you
know what happens is you get really
drunk at night and then your whole day
is recovery you hit a sauna you hit the
gym you're just trying to hit the steam
room every day steam room every day
sweat it out and then you drink again
that night because you have to reward
yourself for all the recovery you did
it's a vicious cycle it's a vicious
cycle that ends at 46.
very soon Chrysler did it did it he's
still going I don't know that's this
could have a bad ending that's true I'm
worried I feel like crush is gonna die
on like a go-kart accident that's gonna
be some twist that no one sees coming or
usually he gets like E coli from the
spinach salad or something you're like
that's what got him he's gonna slip on a
roller skate or something yeah Sam
Kinison like he quit yes and then a
drunk driver killed him perfect example
yeah he was drunk he might have swerved
out of the way uh-huh true drunk drivers
it's like negative numbers it might be
okay ah if he was coked up he could have
seen it coming you know he would have
been ready but that was uh that was
crazy I mean Kennison and Hicks dying
super young yeah those are like like the
edgy dudes of today I know one was lung
cancer pancreatic cancer oh okay great
crazy so keep smoking kids oh what I was
getting you before before we get into
the tour stuff I'm watching um
I'm watching that movie Blackberry it's
a new movie with Glenn Howerton from
It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia
and uh he's great in it Jay barishelle
it's a good movie it's cool it's it's
well it's like it's like nerdy Wolf of
Wall Street oh all right you know but
anyway I'm watching it and
I'm not giving anything away because
people know the true story but it's they
were completely destroyed by the iPhone
that's what destroyed Blackberry it's
like I'm reading it coinciding with this
book I love that and uh
it is amazing that it's like one thing
is dominant and then the next thing just
destroys it there's no just like we're
still kinda here they're [__] they're
there but it's like they're doing other
stuff it's like Barry it's like
Blockbuster it's like cyber well they
were completely out but I think
Blackberry does like cyber security or
something yeah they do some stuff
but yeah but like you know the name
still means something but but iPhone
you're like yeah it's over they were
they were the whole thing like No One's
Gonna want to like do the clicky they
want the clicky thing yeah and the wheel
the rolly thing was fun the [__]
whatever that was yeah you worked the
clay yeah yeah I've taught a lot of kids
yeah you'd see guys with a Blackberry
like that guy means business like it
felt it felt you were important you were
handling [__] just scrolling and that
type of thing sometimes I dip my nose on
it
you lick it
yeah you suck on it yeah wow that's I
love stories like this it's a good movie
it's a good good flick uh and and the a
jobs book is incredible it's a Dudu
wrote the Einstein uh the Einstein book
also oh no he does a lot of Bio bios but
uh really [__] good all right I mean
I love a good bio biopic bio book I'm in
I got a bit can I run a bit by you I
know it's early but it kind of goes off
what we're saying
so here's an idea I have for a bit and I
don't know if there's anything here but
it's like
um
all these movies now are about like I
guess the premise is like the genres
we're out of stories to tell like the
new movie air it's like all right it's
uh all right is it about Michael Jordan
no it's about his shoe that's what it's
about then you're like all right and
then you're like all right we got uh the
movie flaming hot and you're like it's
the making of the Flamin Hot Cheeto
that's the movie Eva Longoria director
thought it was not Andy Cohen
then we got uh you know Blackberry the
making it's like the new genre is just
capitalism like like how long before how
long before there's a movie where
they're like one man decided to that
cream should go between two cookies the
Oreo story you know you're joking but
Seinfeld's making the Pop-Tart oh well
there you go well there you go right and
it's like uh
but it's like you're going to see a
premise where they have to create drama
where they're like the cream will never
work so you can't put it and he'll be
like I have to try you know all right I
guess the dialogue was good I don't know
but it's like that's that's what we're
dealing with yeah they're out of stories
they're out of stories and we had Wall
Street in the 80s yeah that's kind of
about but yeah you're right it used to
be about Vietnam or something coming
home from Nam or they still make war
movies I guess and stuff like that but
it's just an observation that no it's
like a whole new genre yeah I take that
over a Marvel movie I would too yeah but
as I said there's a good movie
Blackberry is very good yeah as long as
the story is good you know because
flaming hot it's literally about Cheetos
but a janitor and people say he didn't
even do it people were like it's
[__] all right but it's like a
feel-good Latino story so they're like
nah he did it yeah he [__] did it
right but yeah Cool Hand Luke's like a
guy getting out of jail and all that
[__] and uh yeah you're right it's we're
really scraping the barrel and it's all
products yeah because that's the last
adventure we don't have Adventures
anymore or whatever they have a crazy
Uber ride or something you know you got
to go to you got to go to these guys
because these are like the new um Risk
Takers yeah
speaking of Cool Hand Luke I watched
this movie Harper last night and I think
you'd really like it I never heard of it
me and Mark are both of us yeah I didn't
think have you ever have you ever seen
it I think you've never heard of it
never seen it so it's uh like right
before Cool Hand Luke maybe like two or
three years same writer
and it's Paul Newman Peak Paul Newman
yeah he plays like a Richard Marlow type
Phillip Marlow oh sorry Philip yeah yeah
that's true I love Paul Newman he's
great because he's a sex symbol and he's
510. oh nice gives me hope
you know that's five Tenors where they
they did some Tinder uh study and it
says once you get past six
foot the the the likes just plummet so
we need our 510 sex symbols out there
Newman and half Jew
so Mark you said that you were in
Australia and you're cooking up a lot of
new bits a lot of new bit I gotta tell
you I'm just getting away from America
the news and Trump and politics and
school shootings and all this [__] and
the you know we're very Doggy Dog over
here and it's just chill there and uh I
I was my my creativity was popping
because I have you know I got the days
free no pods writing big shows the wife
I'm with the wife are you still able to
ah we got a couple fights and I finally
got some alone time so I could you know
really uh ride it out you just tell her
she's been gaining weight just so you
can go to the coffee shop and crank out
some material wow you have Let Yourself
Go Mark all right perfect two hours
let's do this all right right exactly
she's like who are you dming oh this is
your sister all right finally a little
alone time yeah but uh yeah great great
trip and just seeing new [__] and
getting out and seeing the Sydney Opera
House and taking a ferry and going to
Bondi Beach and going to New Zealand and
you know all this crazy [__] was like
getting the juices flowing again because
you know we kind of get a little rote
out here you wake up you have your
hard-boiled egg you go do a pod you get
drunk at noon you hang out with us you
put a belt around your neck the [__]
mask on it's the same day every day it's
hard on a black person you do a puck you
know whatever it is and you do shows at
night and then you yeah you call your
dad he doesn't answer whatever it is but
out there it was all new and I think it
got the Mojo going
anything that breaks up routine we're
such creatures of routine I mean yeah I
think about that all the time is I'm
going away I'm going to Europe you know
I'm going to London that'll be good
it'll be good for me to just get away
for a while definitely seeing new
buildings yeah and they have different
Expressions so you could go out and you
want your Australia Chunk Up Front you
know you want to do the a fish out of
water we finally get to be the novelty
we're a bunch of straight white honkies
out here so being over there you're
exotic it was fun to be exotic it'll be
nice to be like stabbed in an English
accent for once
but he's got a little peaky blinders
head on you okay take it what the hell
quite a good seven ain't it yeah yeah
exactly so uh yeah just had a great time
and you're all your brain is always open
because you're like oh I need a new I
need a new bit about Australia to do
them up top so uh yeah great time and uh
it's all these big theater shows because
you never get to go out there so your
tickets really sell and you don't want
to let the theater down so you got to
really bring the heat and I had just had
a great time but I definitely drank too
much did you cook up a new bit oh you
want a new bit let's get a bit all right
let's get a bit going
okay so uh I've been playing a lot of
video games lately and the lady hates it
what do you play I've been playing uh
well they're all like Mario Kart and
Donkey Kong I got a throwback but she's
getting annoyed with it
you good yeah I'm wondering if we did
this one already oh did I caught the
boss yeah you did this one oh [__] look
at me I'm like the drinking podcast
sorry let me let me uh hold on I got
another one did I do the only fans no
okay I think I told I ran this by you
but I finally cracked it hit me my buddy
does only fans he's a hot guy and he's
always bitching about making no money
and I'm like
well I'm not a woman but you wanna women
already hate dick pics and now you want
them to pay for them you want a woman to
pay for a dick pic that's insane that'd
be like me paying to see the to see to
get yelled at at Target you know like
the thing I don't like you know you get
it the thingy women don't like about men
you want them to pay for now I don't
want to get paid to have for you to have
a mood swing blah blah blah and then I
talk about how dicks are so uh scary to
women but they also like them too I feel
like women look at Dicks the way I look
at crawfish you know like you see one
out in the wild they're weird and kind
of scary but in the right mood I'm like
I'll suck the head you know that's good
that's good so that's been killing for a
second I was like maybe you should go
oysters but I like to suckers I started
with oysters yeah what do you say
something about oysters are the danger
yes it's pretty bad but yeah yeah you
can get poisoned or an STD or whatever
but then it goes on to uh he's like ah
well it sucks it's not fair the men make
less money and I'm like you gotta suck
this one up because this is only fans
for men as rwnba nobody wants to see
that I love that you know and that's
that's you're doing this by me I love
this one yeah but I needed some more in
the front so I it's really cooking now
I like that that's really good that's a
working bit no that's good
um the only the fact that it's like you
like this but it's also
it's bad right right yeah just sorry
nobody likes it's like you like I think
one of the things is like if you're in a
relationship you like one dick
uh like I'm not I'm not imagine being
that specific yeah only day
imagine being that specific with with
crawfish
uh there's only one I like and there's
just like okay well which one you're
like yeah they pour out a basket on the
table and you're like that's the one
that's my crawfish right there yeah so
uh that's the new bit it's really it's
really cooking and it's it's blowing it
out but the only fans think it's a grown
from women and I'm like well much like
only fans of met for men I don't support
it either you know like you don't even
watch it ladies yeah and I'm not
watching guys and only fan I'm not
giving them money so I get it
but some dudes are doing well in there I
guess yeah but women women really make
up yeah you're right gay dudes will pay
dudes are supporting dudes are keeping
only fans afloat yeah for other dudes
and women yeah you're right I told Mark
I said that uh you know for women what's
worse an unsolicited dick pic or
watching the WNBA and I was like well
with Brittany Griner you get both
that was definitely gonna grown but I'll
try it
um
yeah I like the first part of that where
it's like which is which would you
rather watch yeah uh if I send you a
link of either you ain't opening it
you want to meet someone without that
true yes
um although I've been watching I watched
some WNBA yesterday because the Liberty
are [__] good right now so to be
honest Stewart's a stud ah they're
they're not they're playing the Barclays
again they're back they were in the MSG
for a while they weren't selling tickets
they got thrown to Westchester now
they're in Brooklyn again so wow you
know they should have uh this is gonna
get offensive but it'd be more fun if
the names were feminine like the the
Cleveland craps you know like the uh the
Memphis menopause or something like that
you know let's get it let's go all the
way the Phoenix you know what you did
yeah
Sacramento do I look fat in this
oh man Racine used to have the best joke
remember micro scenes joke about worst
pedophile a pedophile Joker hear the
whole thing about like this guy is the
worst pedophile that was the headline
but it turned out he molested like 47
kids really sounds like the best
pedophile his bit was like the worst
pedophile can't get his van to start
yeah he's giving kids circuit circus
peanuts is candy WNBA WNBA cards
that's a good that's a good angle killer
killer bit Mike you were seeing funny
bit we should put our money where our
mouth is and go to one of these WNBA
games I would go I've been I like it I
love basketball and they're getting paid
so little that it's pure love of the
game yeah I mean it's literally the
mascot for the Denver Nuggets makes 625
000 a year the highest paid WNBA player
it's like 235. oh wow not even a
thousand two dollars and 35 cents a year
if you change
no can I yell at them as I would yell at
a male
you suck you're you're a piece of [__]
but a lot of the insults that male games
don't work at the WNBA games like yeah
you get paid so much and this is how you
perform you can't say it oh yeah that's
two or two on the nose yeah the insults
got to be like you make what you deserve
yeah playing like this that's the insult
yeah I'm just gonna go out there with a
big pot and a spoon and go hello I have
no dinner
joking
idiot all right but yeah hey good stuff
but yeah Australia highly recommend it
it's really a special place and it's
clean and it's safe I have a breakdown
of what the difference between Australia
and America is because they're better
than us in a lot of ways they're clean
everything there's no graffiti there's
no garbage everything's safe there's way
less crime they don't have guns they
don't have the opioid crisis but
it's all like this in Australia
very regular very mediocre here we got
highs and lows we got the guy doing
heroin under the overpass but we also
have Steve Jobs we have exceptionalism
which does come with you know uh some
some poverty and some horrible school
shooting and all that but we also have
these giant great actors and and
Hollywood and then the the Freedom Tower
and all this [__] and Joey Chestnut they
don't have that you know they they're
all very even keeled yeah I thought that
I thought that would well I know they're
really you really forced Chestnut in
there in terms of the industry you know
we got LeBron James over here you know
we got I I totally get what you're
saying you need the highs for the lows
yeah we got Clooney yeah they got nobody
they got they got the regular guy who's
who's nice and he goes to work and he
has a he's a good to his family but
you're right no and I understand for you
got the inspiration because this is new
to you but if you were always there
maybe you wouldn't hit that level of
inspiration like there is something
about how fast-paced New York is like
yeah always kind of get material and you
know uh when I'm in a slower place I
don't feel I don't feel the inspiration
exactly exactly which helps for you know
letting art in and creativity in but
that's why they all leave they got Jim
Jefferies who's a talented funny guy he
got the [__] out but he came up in the
UK I think I think you're right I think
he came with UK so yeah but now he's
massive in Australia because he's one of
their own exactly but they hated him
like Ronnie Chang told me I was texting
with him when I was over there he's like
they never appreciated me they never
gave me a spot yeah yeah he's like [__]
them I don't know if I'm supposed to say
that he says it all over his Instagram
oh okay okay Singapore in Australia oh
all right great because they never gave
him a chance and then he comes here he's
flourishing he's got multiple Netflix
special he's on The Daily Show he's
doing this he's doing that so
you gotta get out it's like kind of a
small town feel in this giant beautiful
city we did uh we did a two-week run on
the bus and it was it was excellent it
was my last bus run of the Year probably
but it was you know we started in
Hampton Beach New Hampshire Portland
Maine Foxwoods and Connecticut you know
the casino though we go down and we hit
like uh
all over the south I mean started in
Richmond Virginia but then we really
started getting it like the Memphis
Chattanooga Knoxville wow you know
Birmingham Alabama are these places you
wouldn't normally get to
I mean Birmingham I don't believe they
have maybe they have a club I don't know
but I know Knoxville does yeah I've
never been uh
uh Birmingham it was great yeah did you
sell it in Memphis I know that's a tough
Market I did fine sell it out but I did
it was a big room it was a big you know
for that City and it was it was a great
show oh great that's when we were like
but then like the people that come out
are [__] happy are there yeah so you
know Chattanooga I mean Knoxville might
have been the best show of the Year wow
is that right they were on fire it was
like it's so good I was watching veteran
I'm like man he's doing well this is a
weird change and uh he's killing no he's
just ripping and uh I was like ooh it's
gonna be good I think I have a good
feeling all right it's in your energy
level when you fly into let's say
Memphis or when you drive in the night
before like dude I feel better when we
take the bus I sleep you know what's
great about the tour buses you get uh
you you get sleep I mean I I sleep on
the bus you have a day in that City yeah
so if you if you I got you know these
other ones I I fly in we take a runner
it's like you're traveling that day yeah
whereas if you sleep you're just like
okay I'm that was my sleep I'm that is
pretty great and they know what it says
but the airport takes it out of you even
if you just got an easy flight
everything is on time you got to find
your gate you got to check in you got to
go through security you got to take your
shoes off you gotta find your seat and
all those little things and then now
boarding you gotta listen to the
[__] security and all that [__] and
then then you finally land and you gotta
get an Uber all that [__] adds up meant
a lot it's a lot of things and and you
can kind of just shut off when you have
a bus you're like yeah I could think
about jokes we'd wake up and go to the
at to the Y and just hoop and it's a
good way to start at least play it every
day I rolled my ankle on the last day
[__] sad old man I was playing well
because it was like day 12 in a row of
me playing so I was like hitting shots I
was like I'm [__] rolling right now
and this one kid was so fast and he and
I just like trying to keep up with him
on one
and I was like [__] damn oh we gotta
guess this
hey look who's early hello
how's it going what's up man please join
us sit down
right in yeah
boy you smell good
you do it that was a nice smell Mark
farted a minute ago yeah that really
that really helped I came to clear it
out
I can't wear cologne I feel I feel like
too immature my dad wore it what I don't
know I'm a child
you look at me my son splashes on
clothes I'm fine he's 12. you've been
doing it since a 12 year old yeah that's
a hot kid he stays in my cologne all the
time really uh I gotta grow up I put a
suit on I feel weird I don't know I feel
we're in the suit now mainly because I'm
fatter than I used to be I used to fit
all my suits oh [__] then you know
something happened around the road I
didn't want to say anything
and black is living it is
no the
clothes are slimming I just got it got
it it's as fat as I am if I was later
is it just doing the road all the time
and just eating crap because that's what
what does it for me I feel like I
was in better shape yeah I think so I I
think it's chocolate no it's like I go
on I go on these chocolate binges and
it's it's ridiculous that's not a bad
advice you could be doing a Oxycontin
you know
I would be slim
not to bring up cotton but uh oh there
we go that's a rum punch how you know I
like rum punches hey come on oh man
that's my drink of choice outside of a
frozen margarita really oh that's a good
one too yeah I'm a margarita guy really
I love a frozen margarita dark liquor
doesn't fare well for me I haven't made
a lot of good decisions on Hennessy
there's no Pleasant Hennessy Story the
only survival stories yeah right that's
true I I tried the Hennessy I couldn't
do it maybe it's the The Honky in me but
I I couldn't couldn't get over it it
just tasted too weird did you say honky
yeah I haven't heard that I'm trying to
bring it back like and I think last time
I already I was six my uncle just
randomly said it
that's right that's right so you I mean
you've been doing comedy a long time
right yeah 25 years yeah very ancient
wow damn 25 years where'd you start
um just joking comedy Cafe
Houston Texas oh [__] oh yeah you're a
Houston Richmond yeah I'm a Houston guy
damn is he improv there then or no no it
was a club called spellbinders at the
time and then they moved
um where the Improv used to be the
Improv though so spellbinders moved they
had a rain forest at the bottom like a
Rainforest restaurant
so the Improv bought that bought out
spellbinders and then it's just been
improv ever since okay that's a great
comedy town but there was a place called
joke joint yeah the joke joint that was
a rough room I got I got my ass kicked
in that place that why would you at the
joke joint I was such a low-level
comedian that I they said we'll have you
for 18 and I said I'll be there I did it
for 16 in Minnesota
oh yeah the joke joint was in Minnesota
it was in Minnesota that was like their
C room it was like Acme was like the hot
room they had the Mall of America room
and then they had the joke joint and I
remember eating [__] I was getting
Heckle for like an hour 40. I had too
much pride to get off stage but I wasn't
handling it well yeah and the owner got
off he's like that was just terrible I
was like well my defensure paying me
[__] right this is what you get was it
oh man see it not mancia um what was the
guy's name oh I'm a Hispanic guy yeah
yeah the joke joint yeah he was all 45
and like Fuquay like almost to Galveston
nobody yes nobody was coming out like
y'all went to the only comedy club that
I've never been in you're like in
Houston outside of going there for a to
watch somebody in a competition They
begged me to come and I got a loss going
I was like
you know in my own Hometown I was like
yo where's this place it was way out of
like East Houston or whatever it was
right off the highway and it was a bunch
of Hispanic guys with cowboy hats yes it
was my audience yes and they hated me
yeah they would have hated me as well
that was a Juan Villarreal room like
Juan Villarreal can come there and just
sell out for like two months exactly I
had a friend years ago uh run on opened
for you and he was like this dude's
really funny I remember he was telling
me this guy Ali said he was really funny
and it was at the Syracuse Funny Bone
and I remember he goes this is the worst
[__] room or I'm watching this dude
on on the table just like the wait staff
is being loud and they're talking
through your set and you and you said
something along the lines of like you
guys aren't doing nothing for me to the
wait staff and I was like oh I like that
guy I like that he like called him out
for talking to his set it's like yeah
the I think the weight staff was being
loud the people were being loud and it's
got I remember that night this guy
um
I was gonna beat the [__] out this dude
cause he he got his him and his wife was
awk and I'm like yo man Take It Outside
yeah and then you go what you got to do
about I don't have nothing to do with
your argument I'm gonna go outside yeah
I'm trying to do a show and then I say
don't get mad at me because she didn't
walk out on you and it was awful and
then the next day
um because the wait staff can really
make a room oh yeah shitty I know great
if they know how to take an order if
they know how to be quiet they help so
much like how do you stay if you see
that people are looking at me why are
you standing straight up in front of
them yes well they can't see me you know
so yeah go go [__] yourself and then you
feel bad yelling at them because you're
like well I don't piss the staff off and
have them turn on me so it's a tough
spot and I tip the staff in clubs at the
end like the whole staff just washes
everybody I tip everybody I'm like damn
can y'all help me out we co-workers yeah
exactly if somebody do be rude to you
I'ma say now you blocking me from just
like I'm doing the show the lady doing
this trying to look around
get your ass out the way I know and it's
sold out you're making money lady
goodbye I don't know if anyone's selling
out that room yeah baby dad that was a
tough one like one night okay yeah I
think they canceled all other nights
Syracuse is it's like oh it's I I beat
him up pretty good though it it took me
I want that maybe like
five times I went to Syracuse five times
that's like nam I did four tours and I
thought they just started rolling in
like oh Ali is coming again yeah yeah
Syracuse that's the one that's one of
the ones you shirk on the calendar and
you're like [__] hey I'll just get
through it yeah that in Albany OH
similar why don't you leave Albany the
Crowds Are Better than than true
Syracuse but like whenever you're in a
mall you're like I feel [__] corny
what about
um Levity Live it's another once you
leave the city it's like those are like
the weirdest crowds sometimes yeah they
in you like people coming out of Target
and like yeah he's here exactly
I don't have a lot of overlap with
Auntie Anne's pretzels that's who's
coming in you know it's some it's some
places that
some comedy clubs that are awful because
the bar is in the showroom and while
you're performing oh man
like the blender hey um hey that's your
frozen margarita that you ordered
hey I'm working no I know right who's at
the comedy store yeah in La Jolla that's
a good room though I love the room great
room but it's a lot of it's a lot of
martinis being shooking back there I
know yeah um which they don't have that
at Hamilton this is the only art form
will you hear that [__] but that but
that room there's something magical
about that room where like it is hard
not to crush that that's a great room
it's a great room I think it's it's so
simple yeah they they it's not a lot
going on it's popcorn and drinks because
San Diego is just good it's just good
for comedy 10 minutes away is the beach
it's beautiful beach the the seal like I
took my family
um this time the first time I went I
went by myself manager I took my family
this time and
everything was going well there at the
beach they doing everything and for some
reason we forget that um we have a
daughter that's allergic to seafood and
my my the lady who live in my house
affects me what I call her she she calls
me and says hey they were playing with
crab and all this and immediately I'm
like wait a minute playing with crap
what was what was Hanan oh she was over
there too
so everything is going well and then she
calls me
where do you have to go it's like to the
emergency room Hanan looks like mask
right now she's I'm talking about her
whole head was swollen it was crazy
that's like a 15 minute delay she just
playing with crab with her brother
Optimus she looks like like somebody
just start pumping air oh my God it was
crazy so on the all the pictures of the
vacation it looks like she's being extra
fly because she has all these pink
um these pink flower Shades yeah no
we're hiding that we have a swollen job
I can't believe your kid is Jewish
that's crazy no shellfish man yeah I
want to see those pics I ruined myself
graduation photos because I I was in
like seventh grade and I puked I drank
so much I puked so hard that all the
blood vessels in my face popped so every
family photo it looks like I have
freckles but it's literally blood
vessels in my face that's how much I
puked damn I remember that as a kid
they'd get the red eye you know the
bloody eye yeah those were I got knocked
out in college and I had to take a photo
two days later and I had the biggest
like egg like a brown egg on my face
under my eye was brutal so I'm just
hugging my mom like you know I'm like 19
just big old knocked out yes Mardi Gras
it was uh it was a wild time what you
was going to skip past The Knockout
story well I'll give the click I got
knocked out but me and my family was
taking pictures
what happened quick version we're all
out drinking you ever been to Mardi Gras
in New Orleans I'm from Houston okay
drive right away several times good
point all right I still have vomit on
the street
so we're on St Charles being like five
friends or whatever and this kid catches
a spear and you catch a spear that's the
number one you know Big Ticket item and
these college kids were going hey kid
give me the spear and they're pulling it
and he's like that's my Spears like a 10
year old kid and we're like hey let's
give the kids a spear what are you doing
and to like who the hell are you guys
and it was probably like you know nine
of them and we're like well you just you
know you're bullet this kid and then
they're like what are you gonna do about
it and one of them pushed me and like
out of a movie he had the friend behind
me doing this [__] and so I fell right
over him and then I'm on the ground
getting wailed on and then my look up
you know you see your friends getting
beat up they're outnumbering us and uh I
remember a vivid memory of being on the
sidewalk and I see my friend also laying
down and he's getting his face stepped
on by a Doc Martin he's like preppy Polo
wearing frat guys so uh before I know it
the cops come they break everything up
and we're all good we're like that was
crazy holy [__] we're wiping grass off
us that was wild and then one of them
goes I think that's one of the guys and
he was running up from uh the other way
and I went huh and he hit me with a
running start went out pissed myself
and uh woke up on the lawn to all my
friends fighting and I was just like uh
and that was it they all just walked
away like Cobra Kai out
you sound like [__] dweebs yeah they
they suck did the kid did they get the
spear they never got the spear so we
saved the kid I could have used that
spear though
I'm thinking he need to help you with it
nothing he was 10 but I had a big old
big old rock on my face I had a black I
had a good black eye before yeah real
good one real Shiner got I got a Bob
Marley festival oh yeah yeah back turn
dude stole me hit me now and I beat the
[__] out of him but my eye was swelling
up wow he called me pretty good he's
just a sucker punch for no reason
well when I found out later what was
behind is basically still for no reason
behind us with this this girl
misinterpreted something I said and he
told him and the [__] was totally not
what I said yeah and he took her word
and
he stole me damn I beat his ass twice
though like I was I was I beat his ass
then and then I saw him again and I beat
his ass again I'm like because I was
still on
this the Fairway like my back was turned
damn that must have sucked for him to
see you again dude named Richard I beat
his ass wow how'd you get his name yeah
I knew him I already knew it oh you knew
it yeah he was a he was a rapper that
was what happened was at this show he's
rapping pretty decent artists at the
time and I'm sitting there and all I
said was man this would be better if he
had some dances like if he had like a
stage show yeah so whatever she goes and
tell him like I said he sucked or
something oh [__] and then so he took
the event but yeah in long story short
he don't rap anymore either
that's how long that career lasted yeah
well Richard the ass whooping you know
you lose a lot of street cred if you're
a rapper and a comedian beats the [__]
out of here
this was I was young I was still I
hadn't even went to prison yet so I was
still in the streets just in the streets
I'll go to prison when I was 19. oh wow
that's pretty hard so young yeah damn
but when you walked in they're like
that's the guy beat up Richard he had a
little cred yeah it's man I still I
think I'm still mad about that if I just
thought about it if I wanted a rich I'd
whip his ass again
I can steal her like I've never been
cool with us with the Sucker Punch have
you ever lost a fight
um
it's okay we're all friends here that's
okay I'ma say yes okay I'ma say
I was okay this is how I lost all right
so I lost
because I did something my father told
me never to do he told me never slap a
man while he's down so I'm a I'm a train
boxer like I oh really fighter okay so I
get into it with this dude named Rich
cat while I'm locked up in the county
jail I get it I get into a rich cat and
how old are you here I'm 19. I'm just in
the county and I get I drop Rich cat and
I'm listening to the people on the
sideline and somebody say slap his ass
and I slap Rich cat
and man I don't know what happened after
that but I know it was it's eight still
tables in the day room yeah and he
introduced me to all eight of these wow
I don't know it's like when I slap them
I don't know how my arms got by my side
it's like he grabbed me because he was
down his knees when I slapped him and
he's like he grabbed me and picked me up
and he's like I want a roller coaster
it's like he was a boom and every time I
stopped you just slam me on the table
and the last table I just went I just
came just
and he stood over me don't you ever
[__] slap me and I said yes sir
so I won the first half and I lost the
second
from the southwest side of Houston wow
so how long were you in prison six years
that's a long [__] time yeah like
four years from a decade I thought about
that the other day I'm like damn four
more years that have been 10 years yeah
10 is nice nice round number no I I
don't know
I didn't need a knife
as well if you if you don't know let's
just Round Up to make this up a fat
number here what uh charge yeah what was
it drug trafficking they call it
delivery delivery delivery of a
controlled substance it's not delivery
it's cocaine
damn now we have so many different
Delivery Systems but yeah that's
something this guy right here yeah he's
on it and he makes a good oh yeah it's
good as [__] so you uh you how do you
get into that oh drug dealer yeah oh
it's kind of like a neighborhood thing
you know like you know you meet some
money
yeah hey you want to sell drugs
actually just being outside with my with
my friends like let me not say my
friends people who are outside and you
just happen to be in the neighborhood
Who because my mom had a job I didn't
have to sell drugs like to take care of
my family and my mom had a great job I
was just outside being a [__]
knucklehead yeah and decided hey let's
pick up being a pharmaceutical a street
pharmaceutical rep you know and did you
did you start with the weed and then
move up to code no straight we wasn't a
big thing back then like I don't I
didn't I don't think I knew anybody who
was selling weed oh really I think that
was like a giveaway right right we
started I started with what they call a
50 pack a 50 pack of Coke really but my
father sold Coke oh [__] powder when it
was in powder form yeah you know before
crack you know it was like everybody was
too neat he used to sell to a bunch of
lawyers so I thought it was like a real
Upper Crust type of thing at the time
that when crack was different crack
bad thing yeah yeah Coke's still around
yeah
Coke is still around yeah crack is out
Crack is out and then like you know
Whitney said he crack his whack yeah you
know
yeah so was your dad doing this when you
were doing it or no no my dad was my dad
owned a carrier service and just
happened to just be selling powdered
cocaine at the time out of cocaine and
speed damn it's like that Mitch Hedberg
joke uh FedEx is a drug dealer I don't
even know it yeah yeah wow so we had a
carrier service and he sold I mean
that's a perfect combo Perfect combo
that's probably how you get it but it's
very trustworthy guy though you said it
was mostly lawyers it was mostly
attorneys that's right did he ever get
in trouble for it no my dad never went
to jail for um code so how did you get
popped how I get pop oh some
miscellaneous people not paying
attention uh he's a guy named Moe he if
he would have paid attention to what I
told him yeah I'll talk about this in
domino effect too the the special yeah I
tell the story about how we got busted
because the feds busted us they weren't
even they wasn't really even looking for
us this guy named Uh Kevin is who they
was trying to bust Kevin came to us
for the product uh and just so happened
they tapping him he he needed five kilos
and we was like okay cool we'll we'll
give it to you
um but we gonna go on a deal so when I
went on the deal with them
I went in the room and I was the first
person in to count the money which which
I always was
and while I'm counting the money I'm
like yo um
but why does what's these Bank numbers
what's these numbers on the money and
dude talking about these them Bank
numbers from the Franklin Bank
I'm like Franklin Bank but he said out
of New Orleans and I just left New
Orleans I'm like maybe it's a Franklin
Bank in New Orleans and I didn't see it
yeah but Franklin 1301 Franklin is the
county jail oh okay so interesting now
I knew that it was confusing yeah that's
pretty confusing and not that well not
once I heard Franklin yeah I'm like
no I don't and then the money was
it was not Drug Money
there was no way this could be drug
money I've been I've been selling drugs
I was 14. so I know I know what drug
Wayne look like drug money don't come in
hundreds and 50s yeah yeah so it's no
20s no tens no fives no ones uh and it's
not like I've never sold a kilo of dope
to somebody before it's like I know how
this money go it's gonna take a minute
for us to count it yeah so I knock on
the table I three I will signature thing
knock three times then that mean
everybody let's go we're not even doing
a deal so I told Mo that it was the feds
I say tell Charles don't come to that
parking this parking lot with the dope
but I had the whole day I had been
saying so I'm like yo man why it's 12
o'clock we at this we're at this Motel
nobody's checking out of this Motel like
this ain't weird yeah like the whole
time I keep saying stuff
and nobody's paying attention to me
right right so your spidey sense is
tingling because it doesn't make none of
this is making sense to me uh but no one
else is it's so weird that they're doing
this and they're not at all paranoid it
yeah and to this day when when me and
Kevin me and Kevin talk about it Kevin's
like
man none of us would have had to go to
prison if we would have just been
listening to you
Moe was this was like pushing off what I
was saying because he was older than me
but I've been selling drugs longer than
him I'm like yo man listen this doesn't
this don't feel right so tell Charles
don't come in his parking lot next thing
I know
Charles is in the parking lot he on the
high speed chase feds jump out of
everywhere I'm running through this
field wow and it this [__] was just bad
and next thing we know we locked up wow
going to court for we going we went to
court we went to court for about seven
eight months what's that process like
when did they just stick you with a
lawyer and no I I had I had um enough
money to get look I had a lot of money I
wasn't like a
street level guy a lot of money so the
price of a key today I have no idea I
don't I don't keep up I don't keep it
with no type of drug I don't even know
how much aspirin costs
I don't do any yeah so I'm holding if
you need me
it's the the thing about at that time
in the 90s early 90s
it was a different
it was just a different style of doing
business in the early 90s now late when
once I you know the late 90s but I
missed
when I really think about it I missed
damn near all the night I didn't I
didn't get out to 97. oh wow October I
didn't miss that much Jordan ran through
the NBA ran through the inside line had
a few hits I missed biggie I miss biggie
and pop
wow
you know what's crazy when I say that
that's when people say wow what
you miss biggie and Pop I was trying to
make you feel better but today
Forrest Gump was pretty good
Pulp Fiction it was a good decade people
people be talking about things that
happened in like 91 92 93 94 95 97 like
man I lost you literally missed Michael
Jordan's entire run I saw it you missed
are you a Houston Rockets fan you missed
both their titles right probably
watching in the jail maybe we watch it
we watching the jail but I've never been
I've only been a Nick fan so
I'm in a Texas prison
a lot of Houston people there
the Knicks are playing the rockets and I
am going in I'm on it's me and two other
guys with the Knicks so Rockets lose
do you understand what it's like walking
into the cafeteria the next morning when
the rockets look like like it wasn't
just myself
with my block that I was on people was
like ah you got your ass but the rest of
the prison knew that I was going for the
Knicks [__] on the record it was like a
parade when I walked in to that
cafeteria they're like
I'm like I can't even eat in peace
I'm like [__] little hand ass Patrick
Ewing look good get the job done I was
like this is some [__] wow what
would I mean how oh don't please don't
pull this up this is my first this is
like my first sports memory and it
really hurts what year 94. oh damn
94.95 it was crazy
I mean how how scared were you in prison
or I mean what was like day to day like
who was gay were you were you not scared
there all right I don't know come on
what are you talking to I'm gonna fight
yes but what people were people in there
did you see like fear when you're
looking around other people were scared
of people away not you I'm like man I'm
I've never been raised to be scared of
nobody I got you they was like either we
gonna fight or we gonna whatever but I
was you know I was in the streets so I'm
a street dude so
it and I'm on the street dude that came
up fighting like it wasn't
my era of drug dealing had nothing to do
with guns all right I think people
forget that we it was like a lot of
Honor amongst these it wasn't a lot of
gun play
buying drugs back then yeah you know it
was just all fair business so if I got
into with somebody I'm just a straight
we just gonna fight but in prison
you have apprehensions of somebody but I
had uncles that already had been in that
was like yo man this is what you do keep
yourself a lot of advice what else did
they say what are the first thing is
keep keeping to yourself and somebody
say something to you if you feel
threatened you you swing first wow you
go first you don't never let no don't
nobody come in yourself a lot of things
about keeping your door um locked when
you imprint but they because they pop
your doors in the morning like when you
get up in the like four something in the
morning they pop the door it's best that
you get up when they pop the door and
you close your door back whoa it's no
telling man I've seen people get ran in
on yeah and what's crazy is I wouldn't
even
scared when I got transferred like so
you you say you will start somewhere
right and then you'll get transferred to
other prisons so
if you were scared if you were scared on
Torres Unit
if you get sent to Darrington you scared
all over again uh-huh I would say
one is a one is a um a minimum yeah you
have a minimum then you have a medium
skill then you have a Max then you have
a super max I'm saying so
but everybody bleed like you hmm that's
the thing it's not like it's a person
here made of something other than what
you made of true so my whole ideology is
man if you
do something to me imma do something to
you I don't know my wife's a bleeder but
that's a whole other thing yeah that's
monthly but yeah but no that's a good
point yeah we're all just people but
what if somebody's big and then they
they're muscly and then they have crazy
training you went to you went to high
school oh yeah you played Sports in high
school
not really skateboarding okay well is is
some skateboarders are bigger than other
skateboard that's true not the same size
as Tony Hawk no he's six five yeah so if
you're on the skateboard thing and Tony
taking skateboard you gonna let him take
a skateboard are you gonna like you're
gonna say something hopefully yeah I
play I play basketball I'm a point guard
you know how many centers I've been
hitting the face
right you know I mean I was a I was a
free safety and then when I played
football you know how many defensive
ends I didn't got into it
you got to give me some tips what's a
move I can do why are you planning to go
to prison anytime soon yeah you never
know am I gonna pop for [__] a kid
you know you gotta give me something and
and we've been demonetized on YouTube
sorry it just happened
I'm joking by the way no one no one who
actually [__] a kid gives a warning
like that that's true no one if you did
go to president bugging the kid they go
all they gonna do is put you in a on a
safe side of the prison where you can
flourish and and be away from marriage
so if you're going down for drugs you
should [__] a kid yeah there you go
right on the safe side get to the safe
side I'll get drunk driving something
you know shoplifting something they'll
get me with something you know we're
great thinking
and you get a drunk driving
they'll put you in prison with the most
violent people in the world you got a
[__] a drunk driver yeah he was a sex
offender or molester they'll put you on
a whole other end of a prison where you
buy yourself and you safe isn't that
weird because crazy because they expect
these people to get the [__] kicked out
of them oh yeah and they and then and
it's gonna happen
um you can't come to prison for a rape
or molestation
murder murdering a child killing old
people
killing women
hmm and people just know you can't like
hide that I guess right you can't
there's no way to hide everybody know
what you mean that'd be a hard
conversation in the cafeteria where
you're like I'm in for drugs you're like
funny story I [__] the kid I feel
terrible
but oh yeah it's gonna get it's gonna
get bad yeah yeah you yeah it's gonna
get bad all right I I would I would I
would tell anybody yeah it's gonna get
bad okay did you team up with it did uh
were the guys you went down with in the
same prison as you no
hell no I Charles the guy who I was I
was partners with me and Charles had one
discussion Maybe
[__] I'ma say about eight years ago
and it was the discussion didn't go well
uh because I saw his wife his ex-wife
and his daughter at this club
and being helpful
I walked the cake out because it was
somebody's birthday party and I walked
the cake I walked the cake to the car
yeah everybody know whoever walks the
cake out that's who [__] the um
somebody yeah that's the only guy who's
walking at the end of night with the
cake he's he's the man yeah so I'm not
even thinking about that I'm just
walking the cake out and I put the cake
in their car and I'm gone I get a phone
call the next day uh-oh hey you um you
trying to [__] with my ex-wife
I said who is this
Charles
and I was so offended I was like hey bro
why would I be trying to [__] with
Roxanne um
what like why your daughter Alicia was
there like why would
I said Charles man let me tell you
something
remember what I used to do
for you when we was in the streets I do
that for myself
if I get another phone call like this
it's gonna be a problem oh boy and we
never we never spoke again Charles knew
I'm not playing that dumb [__] with him
um I like that yeah I'm like are you are
you [__] serious like right now why
would I why would I want your ex-wife
that'd be great if you started going in
on her you're like she's gross yeah I
don't find her attractive
but the thing is she's very attractive
oh okay she's a very attractive and she
was she was like that when we was she he
had the type of wife yeah that
Roxanne was so [__] fine like
so funny
[Laughter]
so like so super like the other people
that used to be in the crew with us she
would walk into the room and most people
just close their eyes like because you
don't want y'all to see you look at it
but it's it's impossible of course
is she the type of woman you would bring
a cake out for you would take several
cakes out oh damn okay she is yeah and
at the time
Roxanne had to be like [__] 60. whoa
and she was still together wow okay let
me say how much together she was
she was the queen of for the um for
Trinidad in the in the in the in the
carnival she was the she was the head
lady oh yeah you know they always
[__] bill they gotta wear that little
costume yeah oh it's crazy wow Roxanne
Roxanne Rock on the red light yeah
holy [__] I'm never bringing a kick out
again I didn't know that was what that
implied
Happy Father's Day yeah
no that's not her okay oh damn what are
the odds oh
it may be
fine yeah
but yeah no didn't want to no does it is
it like the movies where the the
Hispanic guys are over here the black
guys over here the Aryan race Syrian
Nation guys over there
pretty much WoW but it but everybody
still has to interact with each other
because we all work together right it's
not like I'm in the laundry with all
black people it's like there's a bunch
of people work everywhere like Boot
factory laundry the field the kitchen
you work everywhere but it's
it's a it's a race thing sometimes sure
it happens pitching here can you say if
there was drug dealing inside prison as
well I I can say a lot of things about
inside bro I'm not in there no more they
ain't like they gonna find me yeah
there's a lot of drug dealing in there
brought in by mostly the officers there
you go wow yeah
and it let me say
it's a lot of different trades that go
on in prison every Everything is
what's like highest currency versus like
whatever oh man highest currency is
cigarettes oh I heard it was ramen
noodles
I've read that somewhere nah ramen
noodles no that it's not even close it's
like cigarettes so cigarettes to the top
what else cigarettes
coffee coffee okay let me say this I'm
gonna put coffee over cigarettes yeah me
too I'm gonna put coffee over cigarettes
because three bags of coffee get you
killed like somebody
like I could put a hit on you for three
bags of coffee damn wow
all right good coffee coffee
envelopes stamps what yeah yeah the
Staples in there yeah because because
stamps for you to write home envelopes
right home that makes sense yeah so I'm
gonna go coffee envelope stamps
um cigarettes
I didn't think about the envelopes
um sweets yeah that's a big one sweet
what about porn like a magazine
nah um it is way better it's female
offices for that you guys
you know let me tell you something I'll
bring her a cake attraction
attraction is is different when you
locked up what you attracted to with
your your level right now because you in
a free Society you got all these choices
but when you incarcerated no no 80 a 89
year old woman with tight pants on is a
[__] model
hear that Martha Stewart
I believe oh let me tell you what it
what would it get your ass whooped
though
um it's like this is what I was first
introduced to her my name is Denise
Austin
Denise Austin is she the workout woman
the workout the Pilates woman if you
know she wasn't doing Pilates then she
was just a workout
with blonde one hydration isn't just for
marathon runners regular people uh
okay sorry that was there's no period
there hydration isn't just for marathon
runners regular people who just sit on
their couches and you just stay hydrated
too or alcoholics or people who just
it's a hot summer whatever you need
liquid IV's got you covered mix one
stick with 16 ounces of water and
hydrate yourself two times faster than
water alone that gin ain't leaving your
body without it folks plus you're
getting three times the electrolytes of
a leading sports drink that's pretty
good better than Gatorade I guess oh
yeah 12 delicious flavors like guava
strawberry try them all find your
favorite I like watermelon what do you
like Mark I like uh pina colada that's
right feels like I'm drinking again
proper hydration is essential To Your
Health Liquid IV is the number one
powdered hydration brand in America even
that's [__] big that's a big
statement with five essential vitamins
your body needs to thrive B3 B5 B6 B12
and vitamin C do something great for
your body and choose liquid IV and it's
like a poem real people real flavor real
hydrating grab your liquid IV in bulk
nationwide at Costco or you can get 20
off when you go to liquid iv.com and use
code drunk at checkout that's 20 off
anything when you shop better hydration
today and use promo code to drunk at
liquid iv.com nice
hey folks we might be drunk is brought
to you by fume we all have got some bad
habits or two but with a little grit and
dedication we can get rid of those
habits we want to kick fume is an
Innovative device that replaces that
nasty hand-to-mouth habit that makes you
want to step outside for five minutes
fume let you remove the bad while
keeping the Habit make it as much of an
easy transition on your brain and body
as you can fume is totally natural no
Vapor no harmful chemicals and no
electronics just air and all natural
flavors like Maple pepper and crisp mint
I love that crisp mint because you know
it's fun to chew on suck on at you you
get the good breath going too and you're
not vaping like a weirdo with an
adjustable airflow dial and movable
parts and magnets for fidgeting fume
helps reduce stress and anxiety while
you break your habit stopping is
something we all put off because it's
hot hard but switching the fume is easy
enjoyable and even fun fume has served
over 100 000 customers and has thousands
of success stories there's no reason
that can't be you join fume in
accelerating Humanity's breakup from
destructive Habits by picking up the
journey pack today head to fume.com and
use code drunk to save 10 off when you
get the journey pack today that's try
fum.com and use code drunk to save an
additional 10 off your order today get
on it folks and kick those habits
okay so right oh yeah oh let me put it
in a free world do you understand
watching this woman in the morning
and I mean every morning every morning
this the TV is on this lady Denise
Austin oh yeah if you come turn that TV
I guarantee you get your ass whooped I
guarantee
her outfits was a lot skimpier than that
they were way they she didn't have long
pants on then it was all like oh really
the old bikini with the stockings like
Denise Austin
this is a tease this is man let me tell
you something in the morning
oh yeah I'm shocked because there's not
a lot of not a lot of Curves going on
here not a lot of ass oh man yeah but
she's hot I mean I'm into it Austin
assuming in a prison this do you know
what I'm saying he just said an 89 year
old woman is appealing oh yeah this is
[__] this Denise right now
yeah look this thing you've been like
I'm gonna invite her to a show oh this
could be a this could be a love
connection you've been locked up for two
years you ain't seen up you've been
around nothing but dudes and she's on TV
in the morning I'm into it meanwhile
she's 89 today you got a shot how old is
she really how old is she how old is she
right she's not
89.89 I bet you a million dollars when
she was doing those squats she wasn't
thinking boy and that Franklin prison I
am cleaning up [__] [__] oh look at this
look at this black look at this look at
that oh shoot a gun oh it would have
been all type of problems I bet she
still looks good though she looks great
[__] Denise Austin is still hot yeah
looking good Denise Denise Austin is
still [__] hot yeah you don't want to
turn that TV off oh yeah you get your
ass up turning so what was an average
hat and then Kai lente went oh oh on um
oh oh Telemundo oh yeah Kyle I think
they came on oh you get your ass pull
her up
I want to see because that that
telemundo's got some smoking hot ladies
those Latinas they're all Bombshells
what
um what was an average day like in
prison I'm sorry we're asking so many
questions about this but this is
fascinating oh wait a minute hold on we
got kayente coming up he's gonna be
distracted is that her no this is just
the show this is how the show come on oh
really
yeah this is nothing to sneeze at either
I mean that was a joke come on
it's just probably just some loose
performer but all the rest of the dances
that's around in there oh look at this
what is going what's going on this is
hot yeah
yeah wow I gotta go to Spain
hey this was what in the 90s yeah
remember that show MTV grind and they
would just grab this lady right here in
his white bikini all you're doing is
waiting to get a close-up shot of any of
this yeah
you take this back to you you take this
back to yourself okay oh yeah you take
these memories back to yourself yeah
[Laughter]
guys would [__] a wet paper towel or wet
toilet paper roll
who these guys I think I heard that on a
one-person show or something what it was
was um maybe Tyson no the the toilet
paper roll and you pack it with pla it's
a plastic thing you put you put vaseline
it's also and then some dudes would put
like a warm it would be like a warm
water bag like yeah like you put hot
water in it and you could put it inside
the the it was a weird [__] there you go
they was doing some weird [__] yeah I
mean it's basically like me when I was
13. I was [__] the couch I was
[__] the bed I'd [__] bicycle seat
a Kleenex box a sleeve of a jacket you
know my house was ruined your dad never
wore his coats jacket yeah I was looking
for anything what did you have a
cellmate there yeah sometimes I did
sometimes I put them out but other times
I would keep a good one that's got to be
tough it is it was some weird yeah
what's it like meeting a cellmate like
how does that first interaction go oh
this [__] sucks it's like you you
have a um
yeah somebody ever open for you that you
after this yeah like just some random
guy from Toledo right he's coming I'm
Brent and I'm hoping to be it's like
that it's just like that like get the
[__] out of here yeah yeah over here
either way they're like take me with you
in this green room with me but that
guy's opening for you for six years
exactly actually just he opened it for
you until you decide you're gonna put
him out yourself
like I think that and I and I I probably
like to apologize to this guy named
Brian for this this white guy named
Brian I'm not a person I don't like to
hear urine into a toilet but I [__]
hate the sound of it and I used to tell
I said hey man you gotta you gotta sit
down
to use the restroom because I don't want
your floor is important sure because you
keep your floors shine so you don't want
urine splashing out the toilet on the
floor and all over your steel and stuff
and I said hey and then he had a
a prostate issue or something to where
his urine would just drip out and I was
like say man you gonna have to sit the
[__] down man yeah and
and one night he was up and it was and I
was asleep and I just heard this [__]
noise and I gotta I said yo man pack
your [__] up man you got to move in the
morning you got to you got to move man
and he's like what I said man you got to
move in the morning when they roll the
doors for breakfast you gonna have to
tell them officers that you need to move
mm-hmm and if you don't then the next
thing you do I'm gonna I'm gonna make it
till you gotta move damn that's when the
other [__] come in that's when
you know you you gotta give somebody a
black eye you gotta you gotta it's be
some Screaming coming from yourself
right but you don't want to do that you
kind of just want people just to move or
move around and he didn't want to move
at first and I I pressed the issue uh-oh
and
then I felt bad like he got a real he
got moved to another sale
and then every time I seen I saw him he
was he had a black eye all the time
that's because he's dripping all day I
was like yo man um
and I asked him I'm like yo what's going
on with you if Sally was beating him up
just just like starting him beating him
up yeah and
the the worst thing is I beat his Sally
up
and told him don't extort him hey wow
that's nice but people thought I was I
was like his protector after that but I
wasn't I was like I just don't I've
never been that guy to
take advantage of somebody you know I've
always done Fair even when I was doing
illegal business I did it fair I've
never jumped in about I've never
actually even started the fight yeah I
finished a lot of them I've never
started one so
and then I've never liked bullies yeah
so that's that's that's a that's a real
thing with me like even now as a grown
man like if I saw somebody bullying
somebody
I like fighting enough to step in and
like hey what's up yeah yeah like why do
they got to do what what what what God
damn it got something to do with me now
right like it could be not even a person
I know I'm like this is my good friend
I don't even know this person yeah but
I'm not I've never been
uh a bully guy got to take advantage of
somebody good that's a good peeve maybe
we can segue into your peeves Mark you
got any good job
we do pet peeves on the show but that's
a good one the guy pissing uh into the
bowling and Bullies so two peeves yeah I
got bullied growing up so that's nice to
hear oh yeah should have been friends
with me I will I wish
I'd have waited I'd have set people up
look look look why don't you why don't
you go pull that guy over there
beat him up
yeah never liked them no I bring you a
cake out of uh gratitude
I appreciate that guys before we get to
Mark's piece I just ask you how did that
go down with that guy who who beat the
[__] out of the guy who you know who
beat up your Excel man oh the mixing guy
was a Mexican guy but how did you just
you just approach him it's like stop
both no I I asked him I said hey um I've
done this twice it was one guy named
white dog and then it was Brian I said
hey man um
I hit it too
you you whooping on Brian see he's like
man he's mine is what is his business of
yours I said man you're a friend of mine
and
I don't I don't take common to that
God I got tired of talking I don't want
to keep explaining this [__] yeah beat
his ass up and I thought don't put his
hands on it no more like and then I
remember this this guy named white dog
who I was in the county with right
and white dog was out he like six three
white guy real lanky cool ass [__]
white dude and I was like yo um we call
it white dog man white dog and then he
white dog gets sent to Torah we was on
Torres Unit and said right outside of
San Antonio hondu Texas
and I saw him when he came on the unit
because I was on I was on um seven
building he was on four
I'm like yo man what's up man you you
just got to hit somebody Yeah man they
got man they got me over here on four
bills like cool next thing I see
he said he he flagged me down he's like
hey um it was this is weird to [__] hey
I don't know a lot of Spanish
I think Marcelli and then talking about
[__] me whoa and I was like that's
great to know just a little bit of
Spanish
I think I got a bad feeling about that
word
are you sure he's like man yeah I think
they hey I said man don't don't trip on
that don't trip on that I got you
so I think we're on two different sides
of the unit lasting word I say yo
um this is my this is my guy
if anybody put their hands on it's gonna
be some problems
and the word gets back like yo
this is Ali's guy
don't put your [__] hands on
so I went to the the assistant Ward and
his name was Mendoza I say Mendoza um
can I get
two people transferred on the other side
of the prison
to like four building or I mean to like
six building or seven building you think
man what you got who I see this guy
named white dog that's not his real name
I'ma just show them to you and Dexter
manly
and he was like
who the [__] is Dexter Manley hmm I was
like the great one of the greatest
defensive ends of all uh for the [__]
Redskins oh means like we have an
athlete on this unit I'm like you have
[__] Dexter manly yeah only so Dexter
man who was locked up on Thor's unit too
and he's on four building I gotta
transfer to to um to the side that we
was on oh what was he in for cocaine
using damn Dexter man I was like No And
the crazy thing is I remember when
people thought Dexter Manley was gonna
kill me
um oh that's terrifying we did not we in
the day room watching TV you know how
ABC used to do these things about sports
and they would have all these
um they would be running these things by
football players they were like they was
running football players and it was they
was like Dexter melee greatest defensive
end of all
right
so Dexter I'm standing up watching the
TV Dexter's sitting on this bench yeah
behind the thing and we like this
everybody watching TV and this is the
commercial right before they go to
commercial that man says this because
this is when they used to do an echo for
everybody all the time Dexter melon
greatest defense end of all times times
times time yeah yeah and this is me I'm
standing up and I did it this snow too I
said
oh God
I said now look at you
and they thought Dexter was gonna
[__] kill me
it just went upstairs and laid on his
bunk right so he on his bunk and people
keep talking to me tomorrow hey man
um you need to go apologize to Dexter
man I'm like I might [__] apologize
to Dexter man he's talking about man you
heard Dexter I say I didn't [__] hurt
no goddamn Dexter manifest but people
don't understand I know Dexter Dexter's
from Houston yeah he's from my same
neighborhood and I'm like Dexter man
next thing [__] man Dexter was so
[__] hurt right so I had to go
upstairs and then so I said on this bump
so next is like this he's like this
and I come and I sit on this bunk and
I'm like this I'm like hey
oh
I was just [__] around
man
I was just playing with you and I put
this on my children's life on my
children Dexter did me just like this so
I'm I'm like kind of right here so he
did me like this he was like this no he
wasn't anything
like an angsty team
to convince Dexter to come eat and go to
the cafeteria and we walked in together
and my and the people that's in my on my
block was clapping talking about oh they
made up
I was man I was so disgusted Dexter was
so sensitive damn that's hilarious The
Gentle Giant and he the and he man this
dude
cocaine man was do you still know him
yeah I saw Dexter maybe two years ago
jogging oh wow and and Dex is a good
dude man I'm just [__] with him yeah
but in in prison I was like that man I
would just bother people well your
comedian but no reason like right you
know like I was just a but people don't
want to say I grew up there I was a
basically I was a kid
all right you grew up in prison yeah I'm
19. and I I don't think people are
saying this so my birthday October 17
1973 when I was born
October 17th October 21st I am like I
turned 19 and then four days later I'm
in prison wow so I'm a child yeah so I'm
still this goofy
kid that still was jovial in the street
so
not really understanding the gravity
sure of this place like that
so
Darrington unit
dancing unit was the place that really
gave me the understanding of how prison
really works
so this guy I don't know his name
he
I get to Darrington unit and Darrington
is a Max
and it's a guy he has a broomstick
stuck in his side like to his side and
the way this prison is built you it's
too tight for them to put him on a
gurney and bring him out because the the
stick or just keep hitting on the ball
right so he has to walk out wow so he's
walking out and he's coming out the the
sideways off the block right and I'm on
Transit I'm just now getting here I'm
I'm and they got us in a line and they
got us stop and they're like we're
bringing out an inmate everybody got to
stop and I'm standing there and I'm the
first person in line right
so when he comes off the block he looks
right at me and said it's wild in here
youngster
I'm like that's all you got is wow
oh man that's [__] crazy damn he got
the spear
conspiracy I'll be right back ah don't
drip you better sit down
it's got to be crazy to be Dexter manly
and come out of prison your football
team is a different name you know
out of there the commanders but man that
is terrifying you can't go back now you
you've done your time you gotta you
gotta fly right I have no intentions
okay so I've been out 25 years right so
I got I got arrested
for a traffic warrant that I didn't know
that I had oh no okay so I am I'm 43
I had to spend a night in jail right and
this is the terrible thing I'm in a
small town right
Brazoria County I'm Brazoria County
it's all white people yeah I've never
heard of it all white people in jail and
I'm thinking okay I'm cool nobody's
gonna know I'm in here because this is
all white guys
I'm on the show this is not this is not
happening this is not happening right
yeah yeah
white people clearly watch this show oh
we love it and I have a mattress and I'm
going to the thing because I got to stay
here overnight and I am pissed you know
why I gotta stay here with it I got
arrested at nine something in the
morning
I'm arrested at nine so I get there it's
about 9 15 when I get to the actual jail
and I'm thinking okay I'm not gonna be
in here alone you know why this is gonna
be crazy to everybody I am the
spokesperson
for a bonds a bail bondsman company and
the the slogan is if you go to jail
we'll get you out Midtown Bail Bonds I
am the the spokesperson for them yeah we
have like 40 50 commercials that's
running on the radio Midtown bail bond
and when you go to jail we'll get you
out it's all my voice I'm thinking
clearly they're not gonna leave me in
here right right man so I gotta get out
right
so
I um
I'm I'm being very arrogant
Houston Texas Midtown bail bond I'm
being very arrogant so I'm
I'm not handcuffed they don't have a
haircut and I'm sitting there and I'm
talking to the officers and I'm like hey
um
hey my niece whenever y'all get Tony to
use the phone I need to give him a phone
call so I can get up out of here man
yeah and they like what I said man
I'm getting up out of here baby for show
yeah
um I'm I'm Midtown bail bond that's what
I'm thinking and so I mean I'm they got
me in this in this holding tank before
they put me to hold the tank this man
said hey um the CEO
we need to get your shoe strings
I said for what because we can't have
you hanging yourself yeah that Al Rucker
right there uh he said
um we can't have you hang yourself I say
man I don't know if y'all know
but I'm on I'm on TV
and I'm on the radio and I'm well to do
yeah I'm not gonna hang myself behind a
traffic ticket just know that yeah
that's guaranteed they still took my
strengths so I'm I'm in there and and I
said hey I'm talking I'm like man I'm
about to get out this [__] anyway and I
keep tapping on the window I was like yo
see Yo um say man
let me get my phone call so I can get up
out of here I call my bell my Bail Bonds
people and this little young white boy
said
you ain't gonna get out of here until in
the morning now this is with my this is
what my prison Penitentiary history
kicks in I say first of all hey man stay
out of my [__] business
because you don't know nothing about me
Playboy and he said the white guy said
well I mean I know nothing about you but
I know everything about this jail
because I've been here 21 times
I've been in here 21 times and
um it is 9 30. you're not gonna see a
judge today uh I said 9 30 a.m why would
I see a judge
so the the sheriff call I said hey man I
need to see the judge so I can get a
bomb so I can get out of here he's
saying the judge
is done for the day I said at 9 30 I
said he's done all the [__] judging
yeah he needs to do by 9 30. right I
said okay I'm not gonna be not gonna be
in all of this business what time did he
start judging had to be like five yeah
that's all judging Empire he's like no 8
30. nah
he did an hour judge and that's it damn
what is this Mayberry so
where are we I mean this is a zoria
County Missouri so I um had to spend
that night
and I am pissed so I'm going I'm
carrying my matches right I can't
remember matches on this side and I'm
walking past all these cells and there's
all these white dudes and I'm thinking
okay anybody gonna know me and this
white guy beating on the window boom
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom
boom
Ali Saidi
City because I just did the prison rise
story right and he's like yo man Messi
got on boots
and I ignore him and he's the one oh man
aren't you Alex from this is not
happening I said yeah man but this is
not happening
so I'm in there and overnight and I
remember I'm 43. and I and I was I'm on
this it's the same mattress that they
had when I was 19. yeah and same steel
bump and I can't get comfortable for
[__] I'm like
damn this [__] is [__] horrible so
is this guy rapping and I'm and I'm oh
no pissed then this other guy
yelling I need my insulin I need my
insulin I'm like I forget how [__]
noisy
jail is damn can't get no sleep
so they come get me out at um like 5 20.
hmm I'm going to see the judge just the
next day I'm going to see the judge I'm
see I see the judge at seven
they give me a bond I call a bond
company the bond company already they
already knew that I was in there so they
bought they already made my bond so I'm
waiting to get out
and I'm just thinking like damn
and I'm talking to this guy and he's
like yo man you lucky man you bout to
get out
I'm gonna be here for another
three months I say why is that he said
man I just got picked back up he just
got out of jail
for serving 180 days for no child
support payment whoa they picked him
back up after he got out of jail for no
child support he just got done hey there
how the hell is he gonna pay what he
owes he just and his white guy was like
man I said man how much you oh he's like
fifteen hundred dollars oh my gosh and I
was like that's it yeah my bond was 2500
yeah just paid the whole thing and got
out and I went back I went back and I
beat the case but it was the my back my
back still hurts from that one night at
43 sleep on that [__] mattress that
mattress in that steel
and I think it's a great time to go to
our ad Casper thank you
and I think back like how did I do it
yeah all those years yeah I was in there
younger like my body was different yeah
you know I'm So Young I'm very pampered
now I got a very nice mattress and shirt
and I've got uh 3 000 count sheets
like man prison is a hard way to go for
an old person right now it's a young
man's game it's nobody's game well yeah
but if you go you might as well go young
while your body still can endure it's
it's rough damn yeah you ever do the
stint
in prison yeah
Ponzi scheme when I was 22. I did my
dummy you ever do it I've done a I've
done a night in the uh the drunk tank
just been handcuffed a few times and
they never took me in I got oh really
yeah nothing yeah I've done the holding
still but I've never done that yeah you
were disgusting
it wasn't pretty either yeah because the
drunk tank
people don't realize the drunk take is
the most disgusting oh puking oh it's
full of you know somebody
has done a lot in the drug tank I've
seen people go to the drunk tank and
like oh yeah it's bad it's bad it's bad
everybody ends up naked most of the time
because you won't be quiet they didn't
told you all right be quiet we come here
take your clothes you throw up on
yourself there's all type of defecation
somebody to peed on the on the wall yeah
the drunk thing is awesome so one guy
cried it was bad it was really bad that
was me
well you know it's like oh okay I'm not
supposed to be here oh yeah oh yeah and
I was like all right I thought I was the
biggest wuss in here and then this guy I
was glad he was crying my um the lady
who live in my house she had to go to
jail for traffic tickets and I'd never
forget she's dressed up really really
nice when she I remember when she left
the house she had on Heels his white
skirt this orange shirt and she calls me
it's like no I've been arrested okay and
we're gonna come get you out
and she's um in this place that takes
all day to let you out yeah and
she's she's looking like she's gonna
have to spend the night and she can't
take it yeah she's called she's also I
got so many collect calls in like a five
hour period is insane oh man he's like
yo I've already made your bond you good
we just waiting on your guy
she stood up the whole entire time that
she was in there and she was in there
for like 16 hours what
she have on heels
and her ankles was so swollen wow nope
they they it was women in there using
the bathroom they was doing everything
and I wasn't doing anything I was just
standing there and yeah she didn't want
to sit on anything I like
come out with a completely nice white
skirt on you like I didn't move I stood
in the same place I didn't eat nothing
when you first go to jail you don't eat
anything anyway because right because
you think you're gonna get out uh
everybody thinks they're gonna get out I
don't give down how heinous and horrific
your crime is you think you're gonna get
out yeah I just killed 18 children
I'm gonna get a bond they're gonna let
me out I'm not eating anything yeah and
everything takes so long and there's no
urgency in jail you know you think
there's people behind the desk like we
got to get them out phones ringing you
know doing all this [__] but no one's
doing anything how bad what was like the
worst meals that you got in there
everything yeah was anything good in
there no
um it was
that one year
Texas prisons one year
um they took on this thing called they
they purchased this stuff called vitapro
making you make it look by the pro up
Vita Pro was a was some
stuff that you add water to it and it
expands
like a gremlin
what the hell is that it's like a
Vegemite
this [__] was killing cattle and pigs
and [__] in Canada and and Texas
purchased it to and it came in a and
like save is that little ice bucket
right there right that little ice bucket
say it came in that right
that could feed
5 000 people oh wow that [__] right
there
it's like a Chia Pet oh it's like a Chia
Pet for food yeah oh this little army
man that used to get bigger yeah exactly
man and it was made of all type of [__]
that was causing boils
this was this and it smelled [__]
horrible really it smelled like they was
boiling Rubber and and and and see it
was this [__] here vitapro man I should
have a class action lawsuit
I never even ate the [__] I never even
tasted it that [__] was crazy yeah what
are our second sponsor Vita Pro yeah why
aren't that bad anymore guys crazy it's
actually good now damn that was crazy it
expands this is like tofu before tofu
came out right this is crazy so would
you eat the bread around the Vita Pro no
you didn't eat none of they put this in
beans they put it in everything it's
like a it was like a supplement like
yeah it's like a it's like it was like
with a veggie patty is now before they
start developing him this is impossible
oh it was crazy man on the flip side did
you have like your favorite like food
hack there like some recipe that you
made like with something not just just
my noodle just a regular noodle recipes
you know uh a hot what we call a hot
spread or a cold spread hot spread is
like you you would buy canned goods off
of commissary you buy roast beef you buy
chili you buy beef soups you buy all
that stuff and you're a boil your bowl
all that stuff and you'll put the Roman
you'll put that in there oh and make it
more more thing you add cheese and um
sounds pretty good Fritos oh yeah then
you put Ritz crackers on and make it
like a a big spread thing cold spread is
um mackerel mackerel sardines
um
sandwich spread so that's a cold spread
yeah hot spread is cold spread is
different damn yeah but the key
ingredient is cheese and chips
in the soup we do a lot of peaves on
here it's really hard to go into a peeve
after him talking about prison for like
two hours right he's like he's like you
know this the food was horrible I'm like
people who talk on speakerphone
oh there we go there we go oh my
goodness somebody on a on an elevator on
the speakerphone you're like yo
everybody's on the [__] elevator
it's crazy man oh that's that's
definitely a [__] pet peeve of mine
do you have any others anything up top
of your head that drives you crazy
something somebody does out everyday
life that you can't stand oh
so I can't stand the fact that people
don't know
so if you're if you're coming from this
way and you're wanna you wanna make a a
turn like in the media okay so actually
it's supposed to go like this you're
supposed to go to the far end and the
other person was going to so y'all can
both see right what's the seven I hate
people that [__] short top stop short
yes and neither one of us can see right
and me I drive a big truck and I'll and
I'll wait I go go I'm gonna stay there
yeah go and I'm not and I'm not helping
I'm not [__] helpful damage 100 cars
coming I hope your ass run I hope they
run over yourself because you should
have came all the way down yep yeah so
you can see so I can see this way that's
a great call Great call that happens all
the time intersections stop and stop
signs either that [__] rock stop [__]
just [__] stop like why you just
can't stop like what's what's the rock
stop [__] what is this what does that
stop for what's wrong with just stopping
the vehicle I've done that yes something
about stopping and starting again I
don't know I want to just have a smooth
Coast but it's a little get on the
freeway
people who speed
is through school zones people who need
speed through residential areas yeah it
will speed through [__] shopping if
you're in a grocery store why are you
speeding in this parking lot I know
already [__] here yeah and you're
like into a parking spot like did you
need to go 50 into this spot it's crazy
yeah no I'm with you okay those are mine
those are good you're not gonna call his
our Houston ones they're all driving and
all those like people have a lot of
walking my path while I'm walking yeah
you're not driving out here you had a
ton before we we cut them off so no no I
got a few uh how about this one this is
this drives me crazy and this is this
might be a lady thing sorry Fanny but my
wife does this all the time I'll be like
oh
uh we're going out to eat I'll get us an
Uber and she's like oh great so I call
the Uber whatever you know it says three
minutes and every cargo is that it and
I'm like no no it's two minutes away and
then a carpool is that it I'm like no no
it's two minutes away is that it no it's
one minute away and everyone she's like
is that it I'm like have some patience
you crazy Coos I'm telling you it's one
minute away that's not it it's a Chevy
you know it's a Chevy bolt and I'm like
that's a that's a Honda you know it's
like it's like us with their stories is
it over yet two minutes away all right
wrap it up it's one minute away
yeah one star one star one star on that
story
I gotta peeve this is when you ever have
that friend who's like he'll he'll [__]
talk someone in front of you on the
street and they hear it oh you do that
under the breath you don't do it that
bad like a French we're both drunk in a
french guy walks by and he's like my
wall you know he's talking and my friend
goes oh
you can't do it
so you heard me I'm like he's looking
angrily at us that's awkward he's
looking angrily in here
[Laughter]
he's a total bag it's rude angry
Canadian
oh that's funny though that my friends
do that hey man are you they make it I
can hear you uh uh by the lady who live
in my house she she'll say something
loud that lady is right there hey hey
hey the the lady the lady can hear you
yeah she can't hear me she's looking at
you yes yeah looking over here first and
then you said the lady over there
loud ass how about this one this is a
comedian thing you're in the hotel room
it's 11 A.M you slept in you're hungover
hello housekeeping
I'm in the bed dick out you know sheets
up hey I'm good
hello ask him like why can't I hear you
and I'm yelling way louder than you
can't hear me what is that [__]
because what they just want to come in
is that what it is yeah I think they
don't they get paid by room oh is that
right yeah I think so isn't that I think
that's the case well she's coming in I'm
it's I'm I'm balls out you know that's
on Earth
oh what's another a pet peeve you ever
you ever had a a comic that's a young
comic trying to interview you oh that's
crazy how'd you get started oh that's
the worst you know what we just did two
shows together
what's your writing process
[Music]
[Laughter]
no that's bro that's a good one it's
weird when it's just not organic yeah it
just doesn't happen in a natural way it
feels weird you ever had somebody
introduce you as a comic and you're just
chilling oh forget about it you just oh
like in the world you just being a
normal regular person you're saying hey
this is my friend more Norman yeah he's
a comedian
yeah yeah you don't seem funny tell me a
joke like yeah now I'm on the clock
again at this wedding yeah yeah it's
brutal I'm with you
um you got one I don't want to step on
yours what what your peeve no I just did
a piece okay okay do you have another
one I got another one yeah
I could see I think I know you're
talking about but uh
either in a room just you and a guy you
just you and him and he you go uh uh
where would you get those shoes who me
there's no one else around I'm talking
about I'm making eye contact with you
I'm a foot away from you we're holding
hands we're at a bar there's no one in
here we love it yeah you
know it's the same as someone being like
funny you asked just say the [__]
thing just speak stop delaying the
answer yeah right what are you assaulted
just say the answer oh dude here's a
peeve you ever have someone I saw
someone post uh about his wife I love
you forever more forevermore easy
Shakespeare yeah all right forevermore
just say I love you what is this the
Raven yeah come on
I hate it your pan it's also it feels
like an unhealthy relationship yeah you
have to if you have to broadcast it that
much I've been in them I've done it it's
not a good idea comedy pet peeve right
now
um my my pet peeve right now and [__]
Comics who put up crowd work uh I do it
all the time yeah I'm sorry well we just
don't want to burn material yeah I I'm
like I would rather just put up
something else because let me tell you
why
because now
because it's being a thing it's an
internet thing yeah okay
so now you go to you go to do shows and
audiences think that you're gonna do it
too that is starting to happen so they
they like I'm trying to engage hey I'm
not [__] here to do no crowd work you
do that right I gotta explain that and
I'm like yo I'm not trying to make a
crowd work clip yeah I have an act let
me do my ACT I have a whole show that I
came here to do right imma do different
shows every night
not trying to do any crowd work yeah and
somebody keeps
like they keep they oh he's gonna do it
yeah you can see him we do a lot of
short jokes so I think we need to do
crowd work at some point just to like
mix up the rhythm you're a Storyteller
right I mean mostly I mean you do bits
too but I've seen you do like long
stories and I think structurally like
crowd work for us like Dangerfield would
do crowd work you know like short joke
people would do crowd work so you know
the differences between Dangerfield I'm
glad you said that yeah this is one of
my Idols oh yeah besides being better
than us go ahead nobody I saw him doing
it
but it's not broadcasted him doing crowd
work right so and it's like because it
was a different era it was no way to
broadcast it right yeah so if back then
if he would have been it would have been
the internet then it [__] he would have
probably did it but now
it's like
because it's on the internet
and people think everything on the
internet applies to every comic right
because now
say it one comic I I hate anything that
one comic star is doing for a reason and
then everybody starts doing it for
something I know the side the side clip
God damn it how many goddamn oh I'm
gonna show this right here then I'm
gonna comment on it yeah God damn it I'm
not doing like everybody everyone did
the reaction [__] you know like I'm
gonna here's me watching two girls one
cup like I'll just watch the [__] two
girls I don't need to watch you watch it
but yeah and then everybody had one but
yeah there's a lot of that coffee
everybody doing something but just think
you guys have actual shows right well
look [__] special was [__] awesome
oh hey thanks it was [__] awesome and
it and it and when you dropped it during
the pandemic it's like we I was like yes
we have something fresh to watch so and
it but it wasn't gravity it was you
doing your thing yeah yeah and well you
don't put out like you do your material
it's separate to me you know what I mean
like the crowd work is like a thing to
get people out to see the material
really I don't want to burn material
uh online online for the next special
right because that's mine I want to you
know I want to own all of it you know I
think
I get that yeah I respect that
I think with me
because it's taught in the impede on me
doing so I think it's a personal thing
because people think that I want to do
it yeah yeah and just like what people
think
that
I remember to say they said this this
was Friday
never get it Friday I'm taking all these
pictures and this lady said
I hadn't seen you a special
because I was coming to see you Friday
and I didn't want to see the same
material luckily it's this guy standing
there he said he didn't do nothing from
his specialist that's nice to hear and
and I and I and I explained to him
ladies I said
do you understand that a special
is different from my club show I have a
actual Club show
and then my special is different that's
why it's called a special and this is
the club show but I have
with me I have a lot of different hours
because I have different stores I most
most Comics don't have 25 minute stories
or 30 minute stories I have 30-minute
stories so if I uh our show to me could
be two stories that's crazy wow you
didn't say I'm saying yeah yeah so if I
so just think about this
if I just did my three if I just came
out and did the three this is not
happenings yeah
oh Max got on boots Mitchell in the
mushroom store that's an hour damn just
in those three stores yeah if I most of
my specials are an hour and 20 minutes
hour and 30 minutes so
I I tell material I turn over material
at a different rate than most Comics but
I'm still judged
based upon because I come out and sit
down
I get [__] because I'm sitting down
well why is he sitting down
I get [__] because I'm not fast paced
people come see Comics which I and I'm
and I hope that we all make this effort
to rectify this if you come to see Mark
Norman you coming to see Magnum you're
not coming to see Dan Soto you're not
coming to see Don Rickles you're coming
to see Mark you have to let artists be
artists sure who they are nobody goes to
print to a print show hoping to hear a
Michael Jackson song right I bet that's
changing for you I mean I bet like you
know you know comedians in general yeah
people come to see us based upon what
they already like and it's hoping that
we're something like coaster they
already if they don't already if they're
not already fans of yours
so I'm coming to see Mark Norman I'm
sitting the whole time I'm thinking why
he not like Bobby Lee because he's not
[__] Bobby Lee
yeah yeah so you can't come
to a a comedian show a comedy show and
think that every comic is the exact same
we're all different I think the podcast
hello though I do think that the comedy
fans have become more sophisticated
because they listen to all these
podcasts and they're like oh I know what
this person does you know like if I do
crowd work in an hour maybe I do an hour
ten in a if I do a theater show or
something maybe three or four minutes of
crowd work maybe less I don't do a lot
of crowd work in the in unless
something's happening I have to roll
with it but you know the material is
what you're excited about that's where
I'm like I can I can make something with
this you know what I mean I can make it
special yeah yeah so that's you know but
I agree I think certain people it's rare
though it doesn't happen in my shows a
lot like I don't I don't find that
they're expecting it you know if I just
I'm like I'm doing material for an hour
or 10 I don't do any of it it's fine
like there's not a problem maybe people
are coming to see you that's coming to
see you got you have your own but fans
is coming to see you new people like D.L
Hughley
D.L Hughley used to be known for doing
crowd work oh like his whole first heart
half his career him ain't got Tori was
the what the [__] best at it
they were you used to get judged like oh
we don't want to get talked about if you
go to a deal yeah so to take that away
from the talk about DL does maybe 45 50
minutes of material and then at the end
he'll talk to the front row uh he'll tie
everything together with the front row
because he got tired of being judged by
uh people think that I'm gonna talk
about them when I come to the show it's
it's just it's like the different
dynamics of how long you been doing
stand up
16 or 17 May 17 maybe 17. yeah maybe and
you about the 16 about that same so I
got a lot I got a couple years on y'all
25 I've seen
people shift
a little different in difference in
different spaces like it's it's
realistically comedy is is a
black white
mainstream thing
either you black you white or you
mainstream
and that's weird wait what do you mean
black white man so have you ever been to
the um have you ever been invited to
Atlanta comedy theater you ever
performed there no
I'd like to not black ah but you have
you ever been to laughing skulls yeah
really white yeah very white
and very white you know and so with me
so I'm black how many black people how
many black people come on Rogan
well you just did it yeah I've did it
four times but how many but how many
black people are on Rogan
I don't know it's definitely less than
white I'm saying so how many black
people
even my audience my audience breaks down
like this is 15 of everything yeah black
Hispanic white asian other it's 15 of
everything it's not a lot of black
people who have that type of audience
that's true Chappelle's got a good mix
but when you start when you start
talking about black Comics who have this
mix you gonna go Chappelle Kevin Hart
then Kevin
not earthquake
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I love earthquake too
but you know what I mean I [__] love
hurricane
but not earthquake yeah yeah you know
not on this Jay yeah that's uh some more
you know not Bruce Bruce right right
Gibbons yeah yeah so you're gonna be
hard-pressed to find a bunch of black
people think come to see dance over well
we're scared
I was scared of that audience you know
and it's the and this is it's it's a lot
of lines and because of this I used to
this is my thing I was always a person
who would open for anybody yeah same
same I'm like you you can see me Houston
Improv this would be the lineup it would
be I would be hosting for Bobby Lee
wow so
and then whoever else comes
even if we the same caliber
I don't have a pro if I'm off
if if they call and say hey Mark
Normandy the feature I'm off if I'm at
home
[__] right I'm coming to perform I
have no problem that this is my home but
that should be that should be the
attitude of yeah any young comic I think
but see but think
I must I sell I come to Houston Improv
four times a year I sell out every show
that I'm coming there to do
most comments are not gonna come
and feature for Mark Norman if they
already selling our show that's true I'm
going to come I love it because because
I I love The Craft
and I'ma come just work I don't give a
[__] I you get I featured for Angela
Johnson oh yeah and this was very this
was this was manicure pedicure Angela
Johnson
huge so it's me Andrew Johnson and Shane
Wayne wow that's a good show
diverse and I'm [__] I'm just as happy
as if but the week before the exact week
before I came to feature I came to host
for Angela Johnson
I just sold out nine shows at The Improv
wow damn Mass majority of people not
gonna do that but me loving the car you
live in Houston stuff yeah I live in
Houston yeah me loving the craft
I man I'm at home
and it's a chance for me to get on stage
in front of another audience I'm like a
[__] audience Thief
I will come I will come to your show and
steal 10 people out your audience wow
they're gonna come
and see me so it's similar it's similar
to being like in New York we'll just go
upstairs the same thing like Gotham
someone come through I'll pop it into a
set the sellers really where we go up
but you don't have a club like the
seller that's a showcase club in Houston
do you yeah the Improv but it's not but
it's usually a headliner on the weekend
though right yeah but it's during the
week it's showcase no it's showcasing
and I I've no I come here and they asked
me to go up at the cellar all the time
and I refuse
wow
I
I I'm not I came to do I came to do the
seller I came to do live from the seller
oh yeah I can't do Gotham
but I'm not pressed when I come to a a
city to go up I don't I'm always like
is it other guys that you don't let go
up
like in L.A I never go up in
l.a's weird and they asked me to go up
all the time but what about this guy
who's been here every [__] week that
you ain't let go of yeah right I don't
need
the practice let him go up yeah but what
you're doing is doing the celebrity
thing oh Ali was in the room and Mark
Norman yeah right man I'm not doing that
[__] I agree what about this guy that
actually needs the time yes you're here
and I think that amongst comics
we should support those younger guys who
need the time yeah like I used to hate
when somebody would come in and just
suck up all the time oh you gonna do 40
minutes just because you uh I hate that
somebody
yeah you hear that Eddie Griffin and I'm
on the [__] list I'm on the list
sometimes the newer guys do that though
I'll tell you like it shocks me but
sometimes the newer guys are the ones
running the light and I'm like what are
you doing oh that's crazy that's when
somebody not running the room well yeah
I wish I when I used to run a room
I used to run a room
go ahead and run it like
I wish you would run the light you'll
fall into the bathroom and making peace
go ahead run the light go ahead and run
like this I I I'ma like you and then we
had to light you twice cool I got you
you do know I'm hosting the show right
and I'm gonna go right back up oh oh
they're gonna get the hot spread it's
gonna get the hot spring
all right well where you gonna be here
we go
we killed it before this even where can
you find the special because I've seen a
lot of your stuff it's all very funny
man definitely check out his stuff yeah
YouTube I'm So independent I'm on
YouTube they have my whole schedule up
there I'm at The Brick House comedy club
I'm an interior at The Improv I'm at
somewhere else and I'm somewhere else
Orlando Cleveland
21st and 22nd July Hartford I'm in
Hartford Connecticut when I go to
Connecticut I'm also speaking in a
prison in Connecticut wow oh yeah yeah
so this was a definitely a refresher of
me going back
you hear that rich cat yeah and I'm and
I'm sitting there thinking this name
this name I was really concerned about
the name of this podcast we may be drunk
but I I I see how I see where it comes
from because I damn sure made me go
ahead
when does this come out
all right okay I'll also be at uh
Charlotte North Carolina August 11th oh
great room oh man I love the comedy zone
Great Club but the the the main thing is
man you can go online you can go to
YouTube you can watch domino effect one
yeah you watch domino effect two those
are my my uh my specials the domino
effect 2 is the new special which is
probably and I and I'm gonna say it with
other Comics being on the show it's
probably the greatest special Of All
Times whoa with other Comics being on
the show so ballsy I know it's probably
gonna be a pet peeve lately
[Music]
get better than us
go see Ellie bring him a cake for
Christ's sake and you're not opening for
me when I go to Houston I don't want you
steal a microwave
if you come you come Houston I'm in town
okay okay because see now I'm doing
these I'm doing these pop-ins
because because I'm bringing back the
real guess set oh I love it so you guys
will be a real guess it people who
people don't know you're not a [__]
guess that you're an intruder you're
you're shooting on the show if I brought
up if I brought y'all out people like oh
[__] they excited like my my my first
pop in is gonna be um June 30th I'm
popping in on Bill Bellamy he's he's in
um in Cincinnati I'm gonna pop in and
I'm saying because Rickey Smiley popped
in on me while I was in in Zanies yeah
and I brought him out first and then he
um brought me back out Miss Pat popped
in on me so as comics
and as notable incredible Comics we
should pop in on each other I love it
and enhance each other I'll be in
Houston very soon so yeah you're coming
to Houston uh Sunday oh here we go
Sunday yeah I'm in tell us the blues
welcome back hit the house come back oh
now we're talking and that's the what
date is that
I know I'm in town Sunday because I'm
I'm on vacation so I'm definitely I love
it oh don't be there that's not legally
binding okay that's true
quickly I got a Montreal Providence uh
you got all you got a big a bunch of
stuff uh a lot of [__] here Albany oh
yeah Burlington that's all theaters
Bethlehem York Bethlehem yeah Phoenix
and we're out in Chicago and New York so
look at New York on sale November 4th so
in Chicago in uh late December so that
just got added nice lots of other [__]
samereal.com
yeah we're rocking
I can't read any of that but uh I'm
coming all over your your wife's face
here it's gonna get crazy got Davenport
yeah July 29th Oklahoma
oh boy oh damn how are you doing oh yeah
Pabst Theater was that the Ace Hotel
who's doing your Balboa theater who's
doing your um your tour uh
uh Outback Outback you goddamn right
Outback is doing your [__] hell yeah
[Music]
all right we'll see we might be drunk
check out how big a cat too get some
Bodega cat we'll see check out at least
all specials on YouTube sit down when
you pay [__]
hell yeah
[Music]
dangerous
woman doesn't look like I remember her
and I get down in the same way
[Music]